I I think all right real quickly he
[__] has some Bourbons he goes to bed
naked doesn't have his glasses on we're
in Detroit he goes gets up to go to the
[__] bathroom shuts the door behind
him and he's outside of his hotel room
completely [__] naked so I'm like
chill what' you do he's like yeah I
[__] covered my junk and he goes I
figured it was 3: in the morning no
one's going to be there and he I tell
you that he gets all the way down there
and the [__] right as he gets to the
front he's peeking around the corner
like 10 people like co-ed you know men
and women come walking and they're like
oh my he's going like no no I I don't
have my key and then somehow he's
disarming they all start laughing and
then the guy goes to go with you and
some woman slapped you on your ass yeah
this guy like oh the guy behind the
counter panicked he come and give me a
sport Cod it's like I don't think care
people care if my shoulders exposed yeah
that wasn't and that wasn't even Joe
having a good time that was just Joe
trying to take a leak
yeah oh I've been naked a lot of places
of crazy